what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and we have really
really big news from marvel studios
today if you have been following the
channel or just marvel news in general
you probably know that we are expecting
some pretty big announcements from
marvel studios at disney's d23 expo
coming up in september we're also
getting disney plus day coming up in
september as well where we expect that
marvel is going to reveal a lot of new
disney plush shows however we have some
new news on top of this now it was
originally reported by an insider that
marvel studios wasn't going to be
attending san diego comic-con this year
of 2022. the last time they attended san
diego comic-con was before the pandemic
in 2019 but before that san diego
comic-con was the big deal it's where
marvel studios and hall h released all
of their greatest new information and
announcements it's what everybody really
looks forward to each year it's where
they revealed phase four and the actors
and actresses who were going to be
playing the roles like jane foster as
the mighty thor natalie portman returned
on stage held up the hammer and they
announced thor love and thunder side
note i saw it at the world premiere on
thursday it's amazing can't wait for
everybody to see it but today we have
news coming from the marvel studios
president the man himself kevin feige
stating that they are actually going to
be attending san diego comic con marvel
studios will be there there were a
couple big reveals in the thor love and
thunder press conference which i was
fortunate enough to be a part of one and
this is very exciting news for the thor
fans when kevin feige was asked about
the future of thor beyond thor love and
thunder he said that they have yet to
explore all of the best thor comic
stories this is great news because there
are just a ton of great thor comic
stories out there but it also means that
hopefully marvel studios isn't stopping
with thor 4 with thor love and thunder
and now with thor love and thunder there
are two thor's in the mcu so who knows
what the future holds but it does look
like in some way shape or form there is
going to be a thor 5 which i am very
very excited about since there are only
a few original avengers remaining so
that's exciting but then kevin feige did
announce that they are going to be
attending san diego comic con this year
so marvel studios will be back at sdcc
back at hall h again where they usually
make all their really big announcements
and here's the deal the last thing that
kevin feige talked about at sdcc of 2019
was the fantastic four and the x-men i
didn't even have time to talk about the
fantastic four
and there's
there's no time left to talk about
mutants
and just so everybody knows kevin feige
did confirm in an interview after sdcc
that mutants and x-men mean the same
thing to him they are interchangeable so
yes he is talking about the x-men now
since sdcc of 2019 we have learned a
little bit more about the fantastic four
kevin feige originally announced that it
was in pre-production and they had a
director who was john watts who directed
the spider-man homecoming trilogy he has
since stepped down and they are now
looking for a new director but it was
made very clear by kevin feige that they
were working on it the fantastic four
was in fact in development so since
kevin feige mentioned the fantastic four
in the x-men we have learned about the
fantastic four but we haven't learned
about the x-men or mutants so i'm hoping
since kevin feige didn't have time to
talk about the mutants in 2019 he has a
little bit of time now in 2022 san diego
comic-con and i am expecting some pretty
big reveals about phase five because
keep in mind phase four is pretty much
over if phase 4 is indeed what they said
it was back in 2019 they revealed the
entire slate and it actually originally
ended with thor love and thunder however
of course because of the pandemic a lot
of things got moved around however with
thor love and thunder coming out in a
couple of weeks that will be the end of
phase four so i'm assuming we are
getting the phase five slate at sdcc if
not which i am expecting though if not
we will receive it at d23 i'm expecting
the big reveals to come at san diego
comic con and then a further elaboration
or possibly even more reveals at d23
perhaps even some teasers not for
projects way out there but maybe a
little tiny teaser for ant-man and the
wasp quantum mania maybe the marvels
maybe wakanda forever who knows but they
do typically show us something so i'm
super pumped for san diego comic-con i'm
really excited to see what the future of
marvel studios holds for us and based
off the last thing that kevin feige said
x-men and fantastic four i am assuming
and hoping that we get some information
about the x-men and the fantastic four
but if i find out anything of course i
will be sure to let you know and i will
be covering sdcc and d23 so be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos don't forget to like the
video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof